hello everyone and a warm welcome to
creating a better world by design
to delight hope and inspiration i'm
trina from the design singapore council
this special webinar brings together
award recipients from the president's
design award singapore
and the golden tin design award taiwan
the president's design award
is singapore's highest accolade for
design and designers
and the golden tin design award is
taiwan's most influential award
we are proud to present this webinar as
the first ever collaboration between the
two awards
this event is also part of the national
design center's emotive design
program lineup for march 2021
before we delve into the session proper
i like to highlight a couple of house
rules
just to keep today's session running as
smoothly as possible
please be informed that this webinar
will be recorded and that your
microphones will be automatically set on
new
throughout the session the webinar will
be conducted in english and mandarin
and if you prefer to listen in one
language please select the globe icon
at the bottom of the screen to access
either language
this simultaneous translation is only
available for attendees who are joining
us
on zoom we most definitely welcome
questions
during the q a segment and you may
submit them through the zoom
q a function and should you encounter
any technical issues
please reach out to our technical team
through the zoom chat function
delight hope inspiration what do these
emotions have to do with design
we are honored to have four designers to
share case studies
and discuss how design can communicate
serious issues
in creative ways that speak to hearts
and minds
and how spaces can be designed to bring
delight and promote harmony
i'm happy to introduce our speakers
today joining us from singapore
mr pan lim co-founder and creative
director of kinetic
also from singapore architect tan kok
hyung
founding director forum architects
joining us from taiwan
mr tsung tsuti co-founder simple info
design
and mr tang hua co-founder luxury
logical
also from taiwan also joining us is our
moderator from singapore
mr jackson tan co-founder and creative
director at black
jackson is actually joining us from
taiwan where he is currently based
welcome speakers to kick off our sharing
today
i'll now like to invite our first
speaker pan
pan is a self-confessed addict to design
advertising and communications
strongly believing that creating work
without an idea is a sin
pan received the pda designer of the
year in 2013.
welcome pan hi hello hello
hi everybody uh thanks for tuning in to
this webinar
uh before anything i would like to thank
the organizers
for making this happen and i'm also very
excited
uh to share this space today with our
friends from taiwan
so yeah i'm gonna start today quite
quickly into
uh my presentation so this project that
i'm gonna share is an exhibition
that we've done based on the theme of
sustainability
i think i'll play the video first then
later i'll go right straight into the
details
convenience it's a big part of modern
life
unfortunately so are its effects 2
billion tons of waste every year
mountains of plastic which take 1 000
years to break down
more plastic than fish in the seas by
how can we get people to move away from
this culture of convenience introducing
the not so convenience store probably
the first convenience store to promote
inconvenience
reusable straws you have to wash instead
of throw
travel tumblers that add weight to your
bag capsules that take
longer to prep and clean compost kits
that require you to live with wormy
waste for months
menstrual cups that need to be emptied
and cleaned
inconvenient zero waste alternatives
like these line the shelves of the store
the drinks bridge is full of bottles and
cups that can be reused
while the freezer is repurposed as a
recycling bin
every product comes with a tag that
spells out the price of convenience
as paid by the earth this is reinforced
by other displays
at the cashier notes on how to live more
sustainably are put in the till
to inspire change branding materials
continue in the same vein
with playful twists on customer service
mottos
we enlisted sustainability champions and
influencers as employees of the month
serving as examples for others we also
created
instagram stickers to help spread the
message on social media
turns out people love being
inconvenienced
the not so convenient store was featured
on the news and multiple sites online
it also evolved into a mini movement
which saw people pledging their support
[Music]
you don't need to be a hero so bring
your waste
down to zero find out more at the not so
convenient store
[Music]
so um so as we all know right um
this topic of sustainability is a topic
that
i find that these days everyone talks
about but um
it can be from like small brands fashion
brands to even big corporations
uh but i think uh people are sometimes
getting a little bored of it so
we were thinking how do we capture
people's attention
so that was one of the reason we wanted
to think of
something more interesting so
[Music]
we all know that uh single-use plastics
are not good single-use items but
actually the
core of the problem is not just about
the single use it's actually we are just
so
used to the culture of convenience like
everything need to be fast everything
needs to be
you know i can throw away easy so
actually this is throwing away and every
the convenience of things made it worse
for the environment actually
so we thought of using an icon of
convenience
to so-called
talk about inconvenience i think that
was how we started with this
project so what better way than to
introduce
a convenience store that everyone knows
every
everyone can identify but actually the
the way we
would like to mislead the audience will
be when they approach this store
they will be surprised that uh while it
looks exactly
like a convenience store uh from the
name design from all the different touch
points
uh they all feel exactly like a
convenience store but it's just only
upon closer inspection
you realize that there's a certain
certain deception to it
then as you even approach the
you approach the
[Music]
you hang on this uh slide yeah so as you
approach
even the shelves right you'll be very
surprised to see
uh all the slow-cool price tags and
everything is just as per how a shop is
going to be
uh even the opening operation hours and
what not everything is designed as
uh as a parody to a real convenience
store
so um there will be different sections
like household plastics
uh food etc etc which is also mimicking
how a convenience store is supposed to
be then um
when you actually look at the shelves
all the items
we are showing they are all far from
being convenient they are actually all
very inconvenient options
like reusable straws like
travel tumblers um like menstrual cups
um and we even purposefully do a section
called the bestsellers but actually
we are just highlighting different
options that we could use and
i think we you know in all convenience
store there's always a fridge filled
with cold
drinks but ours is actually filled with
cups reusable drink bottles and reusable
cups
so that is to parody the look as well we
even have a freezer but there's no ice
cream there but when we go there that is
actually
our bin for throwing away
e-waste and now we cheekily say
the line put putting freeze on e-waste
and i go a bit into the price tag i
think the price tag is the part that
i'm actually the most happy about
actually one of the items because it's
quite cheeky
so actually when you look at the price
tags right it says
stainless steel bottle price of
convenience
one million plastic bottles are bought
around the world every minute most end
up in the landfill or the ocean
but the price of inconvenience not slow
convenience
is 40.62 cents so we are we actually
switch out the regular price tags for
tax which at least the true price of
convenience as paid by the earth
so this cheeky way of messaging is
throughout the store actually
yeah there's a there's there's a reason
why we
have we took this approach um you can
see that uh all the stems and everything
they are all done in a fun manner
because we find that this topic
is getting a bit preachy so our approach
became
something that we wanted wanted it to be
more lighthearted
yeah so that's really one of the the the
strategy that we've adopted
even our cashier does is not filled with
notes of
or money is filled with notes on
sustainability
and in in the till there's also change
used as
uh badges
moving forward moving a bit into the
collaterals in
in the store we have posters um
so so this is a cheeky way again uh
instead of saying like you know
uh sorry for the inconvenience no we are
not
because actually what we are trying to
say is uh don't come back so often
because the less we consume the better
so all these cheeky headlines like uh
customers
comes first just not here and thanks for
visiting
don't come back soon things like that so
this really
uh i mean when we started creating all
these posters we were really uh having a
good laugh as well
uh because we felt that uh if we can
tickle people but
still make people think about it i think
it's a good thing and
uh we also had this wall where we have
employees of the month
and usually these are really to
highlight um you know the
the hard working employees and whatnot
but we instead we
enlisted a group of influencers who are
linked with sustainability
and we make them employees of the month
and we feature them in store and we also
feature them
online yeah we also have this section
where we donate clean reusable bags
which we collaborated with another
partner
so you can drop off your clean top bags
and we will recycle them
and not forgetting a instagram page that
we started
uh beginning of this year so uh inside
this
um ig page comes with all the
information you need to know
and actually in these pages you will see
us promoting some of the
products from the inconvenience store
the not so convenience store
um but i would like to share with
everybody that uh this project is uh
totally non-profit we don't take a
single stand from these vendors we
actually just
have qr codes that uh when people come
to the store they scan
they go directly to the merchant so we
do not take a single card at all
yeah so we we but we are happy to have
partners who
are able to share this same message as
well
and not forgetting fun
instagram stickers so we enjoy
creating all these little little cute
animations
and these are the community that we have
uh brought together so far
so it's really a whole string of brands
well they could be local producers they
could be
local importers that bring in
sustainable products from around the
world
so we are still continuing building this
uh
this group of people this community and
at the same time i think what's a bonus
is uh
ever since we launched it uh we've been
really covered heavily by all the local
press and media
and the the response has been
really really very positive uh the
impact i would say is positive
and it actually gives us more drive to
really pursue this further because we
feel that
while this topic is you know people talk
a lot about but we are still able to
bring
a certain freshness to it i think that's
a good thing
so before i sign off i would just say
that beyond talking
the talk we hope to show people how to
walk the walk
with the stores products serving as
concrete little steps towards
living more sustainably so that's what i
have today
thank you so much for spending this time
with me to hear me
thank you
thank you pan as parched the not so
convenient store is now on display at
the national design center
until the end of march so for our guests
in singapore please come by this to
visit this weekend
our second speaker is salter t
co-founder of simple info design
his company brings together individuals
with different expertise to facilitate
interdisciplinary collaboration and
presents complex ideas in an engaging
and easy to understand way simple info
design received the gpda best design in
tutti will be presenting in mandarin so
please select the globe icon if you
require translation to english
city over to you okay
[Music]
foreign
thank you tsuti our third speaker
is architect tan kopp hyung founding
director of forum architect singapore
his firm has won more than 55 local and
international awards in the past 25
years
among them the chicago athenaeum
international architecture award
for the yale nus college in singapore
and the ura architectural heritage award
for restoration
for the jurong town hall project he
received the pda design of the year in
2014.
the screen is yours
thank you trina uh thank you everyone
for tuning in
i'd like to thank the organizers from
singapore and taiwan
for putting putting together this
webinar i hope i'll be able to share
something of value with you today
um okay so you see on your screen um the
exterior of the
shafa mosque which is what i'll be
talking about today
my practice forum architects had won
this project
in a competition in about 2002 2001
uh the project was completed in 2004
at that time i was particularly
interested in the topic of islamic
architecture
because that had been my final year
thesis at the university
uh it will be more than 13 years after i
finished my
my course before i would be able to get
a chance to put
my thoughts into concrete um
this design was done in the wake of 9
11.
some of you are probably too young to
know the significance of 911.
it was the bombing of the twin towers of
the world trade center in new york
uh by the muslim extremists that i think
led more than
two thousand three thousand people dead
that incident
resulted in a very deep resentment to
middle eastern communities
my most designed tried to remove
middle eastern references like domes and
moorish archers
or traditional minarets and the design
of
of moss we started thinking about what a
modern mosque would be like the key was
not to just design
something that is completely modern it
had to be emotional links
back to what people are familiar with so
we looked at elements that people are
familiar with
um let me just click on the slide
okay so what you see here is the it's a
sort of a
part of an arch the
architectural expression of islam is
actually very deeply rooted
in the architecture of the middle east
as as that's where the religion evolved
hence archers and domes used to
were used to spend large spaces as well
as become very significant
uh emblems of of important buildings
but actually this had more to do with
the conquest and history
of that land than the religion itself
so that made these elements actually
open to interpretation
uh we did within an arch we we
referenced the arch
but mainly because we needed to have
the load the structural load uh
transferred to the ground
in as few points as possible and i would
if we
wanted a column three column three a
pillar-free uh space
because of the large number they will
congregate in these spaces
uh for prayer uh the arches that i
designed were
dimensional you can see from the from
the from the screen that they are not
just uh
flat the sighted arches are not flat but
they're in fact tapering up towards the
towards towards the the top
the idea for that was that it would then
lead the eye
um towards the mirap which i will show
you
going forward so you see these these
arches
and how they were actually
three-dimensional archers that actually
ended up with only eight points at on
the ground level
because it was carrying low transferring
load from the
three stories above down to the ground
you see these arches uh they're actually
cast in concrete
raw concrete uh and they're completely
three-dimensional they sort of interact
with each other
they're not flat at all um
yeah and their their main the main aim
was to use them for transfer of road
um and then as you come up from the
illusion which is in the basement of
this building abusion is where they
they the muslims cleanse themselves
before prayer
and they walk up a series of steps and
and then they will be drawn
by the by the by the rising arches to
what is in front of them which is what
we call a miraculous war
this war in in islamic worship
is is very important because it faces
mecca
as you face this war you will know that
you are actually facing mecca which is
the holy city
so this war we design very unusually to
be canter
it is slanted towards the worshipers and
this
um is actually a wash with uh with
lights
with a with with natural light uh the
idea of this is the camping is to
sort of put men sort of you know humble
man
and put him in this uh in his earthly
place in relation to the heavens so you
know
you know that there's something beyond
beyond earth uh
on this wall on this wall uh i also
carved
the 99 names of allah
and you can see on the next slide maybe
not so well yes in the diagram on the
left
you can see that i'm pointing to a sort
of a
a calligraphic square squares you see
that and actually the calligraphic was
actually done by
we invited the the imam of uh the great
great moss of xian to come to actually
uh uh do the calligraphy and then this
was laser printed and so on
and actually emboss onto the marble
finish
so as you face this wall as worshipers
face this war
uh they will also see on the right hand
side
uh a minbar meanwhile is where the
where the um the imam will be sit will
be at the pulpit
and it will be doing is doing his
preaching
and his uh and his leading of
congregation
um the very next important thing is the
is the arabs the concept of the
arabesque
this is another element that we try to
bring in because it is actually very
universal probably more universal than
the the arches and the domes that you
see in most mosques
in almost if you go to the great mosque
in china many mosques inside in china um
or southeast asian countries you may not
see the mosque you may not see the
arches
or the domes but you will certainly see
some version of the arabesque
why is this important it's important
because it was
um developed the whole concept of the
arab is actually
overlapping geometries and the idea of
job jump is that it actually
is meaning to replicate the concept of
the quran so there should be there's no
beginning as
in the quran there's no beginning and
there's no end apparently you can read
the quran from any point and finish at
the same point and it will still make
sense
so it is and the patterns are infinite
you can keep multiplying
as as is the quran the stories of the
quran and the lessons of the quran
and it's multi-centered and so on so
forth and above all it's all inspiring
so you see
very very elaborate uh uh
patterns that evolve from this concept
of the arabesque
so we use the arab s because it's very
adaptable you can get to the thai
patterns chinese patterns vietnamese
pattern
to uh to embellish most of the spaces in
this
um in this mosque another element is the
is the mineral mineral is a very
important
um feature in a lot of moss because
in traditional in in the oden days you
you would have somebody at the top of
these
minarets which are g very high and tall
and sometimes the moss would have four
of these and they would actually
be be a call to prayer to to to
different directions in in the in the
community
of course now that's not very relevant
they have now become just a symbol
in in mymos i've just used one minaret
and this is
very much a north north african sort of
model
um and the way that we designed it
is that it's actually using the crescent
shape
so you see the diagram on the left the
profile the plan
of the arabesque is actually the
crescent crescent shape this is a very
important symbol for
for for muslims present in the star and
then they're actually made of
metal pieces which are exactly the same
width
and then they telescope upwards and
thereby creating sort of gaps in between
this is an important structural concept
as well because it's about 33 30 meters
high
so it allows lateral load to to sort of
pass through
to the structure
okay so did you see that the the last
slide uh
you see the screens there forming some
sort of pattern as well
uh but then this time the pattern is
actually the void space rather than the
the solid space yes that's the animal
style thank you very much
thank you our final speaker is
co-founder of luxury logical luxury
logical was started by four young
creatives
born in the 1980s and they specialize in
visual art
machinery installation new media and
audio
together the group has created
spectacular installations
that integrate unconventional materials
they receive the gpda
best design in 2019
is
foreign
[Music]
you don't play the song
and
[Music]
so
um
foreign
oh
[Music]
is
foreign
[Music]
thank you speakers for sharing on your
inspiring and delightful projects
i'll now hand the time over to our
moderator jackson tan
co-founder and creative director of
black for the discussion
welcome jackson and let's bring back our
four speakers for the discussion
thanks trina hello everyone okay
um i'm going to start the session today
by asking all the speakers this first
question
so why is it important to engage
emotions through design
maybe you can start with pun okay
so um thanks for the question jackson um
i guess uh for me my my methods have
always been
based on how i feel personally when i do
my work
so if let's say for example if i don't
like people to be
rude to me i wouldn't want to be rude to
others
so if let's say i want a design to
work for others it has to work on myself
first so
for instance when i look like a look at
a piece of work what touches me
uh in a more humane form in a way that i
can feel connected
uh then i will want my work to do the
same as well
so when i was watching the the
presentation from
my colleagues today on on this webinar
uh
at many points it touches me as well so
for me
i think these are the qualities that uh
are important in any piece of work that
is the connection because we are human
in this way
so i i think i'll keep it brief because
i think everybody also has something to
share about this
emotional part about projects yeah
thanks
thanks how about what do you think
um yeah i don't i don't you know when i
design i don't really uh
think about emotions uh but what i try
to do
is i try to seek you beauty for me
that's
that's a very very underrated in our in
our world
uh we do a lot of government projects
and it's very rare
person or client tell us you know it has
to be beautiful
and yet things i think architecture or
anything has to be beautiful
and i think beauty beauty is one of the
very very few things
left that actually uh i think elicit
positive response
if you think about it every day we go to
life we are having
many negative thoughts we are worrying
we are all kinds of things so
if you see something of beauty it brings
about you know happy thoughts positive
thoughts so
that's that's what i try to do all the
time and i think if you do that
well then i think you'll be able to
elicit
foreign
[Music]
and cities projects so first i'm going
to ask han
so you know both of your projects are
really touched on some serious issues
you know but they are also very hard
topics we're talking about like
sustainability you know marine
pollution you know this kind of stuff
that usually people
feel that it's kind of like boring you
know so
how do you make it relatable and what do
you think are the challenges
you know of creating these kind of
emotional uh connections through the
project
um do i go first yeah but it is
so um so i i think we precisely this
exact point right
that's why uh the not so convenient
store was
conceptualized because we were aware of
the many many so-called sustainable
campaigns that are out there
and we were just finding probably
another way of saying that same message
actually
end of the day the end message is just
you know use less waste less
go eco use you know eat less meat so and
so forth so
we are just finding another voice and
another channel to
to share this point of view uh in the
most refreshing manner
as we all know with community
communications
the more we see the more jaded we are
the more jitter we are the less
we will react to it so if we can come up
with an
engaging and fresh idea that actually is
understandable by
by the masses for the better so i think
in in this way uh
yes the topic is serious um that's why
we also feel that people don't like to
be preached
too so we took the
quirky and slightly cheeky way of
approaching this
whole project and surprisingly the end
result became
very positive uh we know that it's
because
of course we got feedback and um
people do busy and they leave messages
behind and say that you know thanks for
doing this
and and of course we can do it better uh
i think we have not reached the point
where we
really can say that everything is your
ways because i've also met up with uh
more um i think uh people who are really
uh more they deep dive into what eco
eco and sustainability is all about and
they talk about
but why is that packaging when you have
packaging then it's not green anymore
this product
i i do not have a solution for that
because i think whoever who puts out the
product needs to have a brand as well
and so far we have not solved the
problem on how to put a brand on a
product
without having some sort of a packaging
right so
and the packaging apps most times is
also to protect the product
so so and so forth so we we are we are
not there yet in terms of solving
everything
but i feel that uh every small step
how small it is is still a progress so
things like that yeah i think that's
what i have
pan why why do you think that people
resonated so strongly
with the project you know i mean you've
seen like you know in the videos there's
a lot of commands and all review
was it so um frankly uh
we have not done a proper research this
i have to come clean
so based on the feedback i guess uh
i think freshness is one thing like so i
mean for for
us for for us but we work on design and
what not actually at kinetic
we are a 360 agency where we work on
advertising as well
so i think understanding that freshness
and a strong single-minded idea is
as important as execution
uh we actually just make sure that the
message that we are going out
that we are crafted be it an exhibition
or is it a poster or whatnot
is sharp in thinking is clear and a
message
is fresh to the viewers and
executed well so i think this will end
up
a result where people resonate with so i
think the
the feeling of approaching so far i know
for a fact that
when people approach the store they
really think that it's a convenience
store
until they walk in and they oh my god
this is weird
then so and so forth so that for that
because i i was
at the store for for a while and just
looking at reactions and
i understand that part that it works
so i think that that's largely why
because when there's intrigue
people will think about it then they'll
tell their friends right hey you know
over this place there's over the design
center there's this new exhibit that's
out there that is um
interesting it looks like a 7-eleven
store for it for that matter and when
you walk in it's not
so things like that so i think probably
that's why
and not forgetting that this topic is
actually
um important topic that actually the
younger generations are
a lot more passionate about as well so i
think we are combining these a few
things together
uh execution plus a topic that is hotly
discussed
yeah so i guess the theme is is
something that is uh in the hearts of
the of the audience but at the same
time you presented it in a very
unexpected way you know so
you know yeah yeah i i i think so is
something like that yeah
[Music]
wait somebody called
foreign
[Music]
okay next i'm going to just ask both
speakers but first i think we can't
so you know we have look at both
projects and uh they have some kind of
similarity in the themes but quite
different in terms of the presentations
you know so i want to ask this question
so what if the projects were to be
represented in the other country just
imagine if
we were to present a cities project in
singapore
and uh plans project in taiwan okay so
for pan
so if we look at the guidebook you know
of the marine dubious
you know uh would you think that you
have the same response in singapore
and what would you think you would tweak
you know to suit the singapore context
okay um
uh sorry i'm i know that we are running
short of time
um i will keep my answer really brief uh
actually i do think that um
city's project is very universal so
uh i would think that it will work well
in singapore moreover we are
we are an island we are surrounded by
water and we have
uh if you search we have quite a number
of beach cleanup groups in singapore
which will which largely they are
passionate about cleaning up our
beach and to collect all this debris
i don't think it will be something that
uh our audience here will not resonate
with and moreover it's presented in such
a wonderful
engaging way uh i i don't see
why it will not happen here it will be
very popular here as well
yeah i think so too yeah
[Music]
so you know both your projects you know
use such a you know
hard and large scale mediums you know be
it machines or buildings
to engage with the audience so what kind
of challenge did you you know encounter
making the designs
to interact with the audience so let's
start talking
okay so you know i i don't actually
focus on the materials
the materials themselves are there to
serve a purpose which is to create space
so it is a space that i'm interested in
because it is a space that people
people function in uh people walk in
people use
it's you know if it's a nice material
they notice it there's some impact on
the space
that's fine but uh first and foremost
always the space
because space if done properly is poetry
and that is the highest level of
emotion that you can elicit from uh from
from a user
so yeah that's
okay
[Music]
yo
foreign
why do you think people resonated so
strongly with your project
uh for me to answer yes
okay sorry uh you know i was a bit
surprised when it was completed
uh there were many visitors uh and many
of the visitors were not muslims
so obviously it wasn't the it wasn't
about the religion or the expression of
the religion that interested people
uh i think end of the day if as i go
back to what i said in the beginning if
you create beauty if you create
spaces that are very ethereal they're
very lofty
um in a way spiritual so they transcend
all the religions
and uh to me i i i think i hope
that is what uh attracted people to the
project
um
okay um we're gonna move on to
um the q a with the audience okay so i
think we have uh received uh some
questions from the audience and uh
some are specific to the designers okay
i'm gonna just start with the first
question
and that's for pan okay okay and it says
here
hi pun thanks for sharing on the not so
convenience
store love the thought and the
dedication put into both the first and
second edition of it
i would like to ask with uh
environmental concerns growing
um what else can we do sustainably as
designers
to not contribute further to more waste
while still being
in the industry that has to create
environmental graphics
print and packaging from brand
collaterals to evoke
emotions to speak to the audience yeah
fun thank you
for this tough question um
to be honest uh i i don't want to smoke
my way
around but i do have to admit that
[Music]
frankly as designers and especially
graphic designers
we print stuff and all that and of
course with the rise of the concern of
sustainable issues
uh there's not a single day that i do
think about that as well
so there are few uh things that i do
but they might not be
a huge step to reduce that much waste
uh i will try to use more sustainable
paper uh
at least with fse and dos or if not um
from the paper merchant they tell me
that this is from a
more responsible source uh that's one
way
the other way will be let's say when i'm
executing projects for my client i mean
end of the day i
do work for my clients and my design
practice is because
the jobs are given by my clients and i'm
able to practice
using their project briefs and indian
there's outcome
um so sometimes i will ask them
uh maybe this one should be a digital
piece more than a printed piece
or do we need this flyer if we do not
need this flyer can this
exist as one of the instagram posts or
whatnot
so we will find alternatives to printing
so that is actually the little ways that
we are working but
there's one thing i want to highlight um
if we can keep the world green
and it's such an easy way to do it then
actually there wouldn't be so much
discourse there won't be so
this issue is something that um takes
everyone to
actually uh come together and do it and
a lot of things are
legacy things where like for years we
have been growing up
you know in in in our society and we we
were not
probably too um exposed to
this issue uh and
and time has passed and he has become a
habit and you know
it's hard to kick a habit and i think uh
but i do feel that
um while how hard it is it's still never
too late to start
so i think we are all starting uh but
it's just an issue about uh how well we
do it but i i do not really have a
solution about
cutting down on design and that's why we
don't do
any more design anymore i mean one well
i can say it didn't do more digital
design
but then i still think that there are
needs for let's say producing
a a very important book you know to be
put in the library
and i cannot say oh because we should
cut down the usage of paper then let's
not print any more things
i'm not going there also but i i do
understand the question
and i'm also stuck in the middle yeah i
guess it's
striking the balance yeah trying to find
the balance yeah definitely
yeah okay uh we're gonna move to the
next question okay
uh exactly when he's the one uh
[Music]
okay um next question is for
hyung okay so ko kyung uh
was the crimes brief to to approach the
mosque
in a more contemporary um you know
contemporary manner
uh did they did they say that uh at the
start of the brief or
it was uh later so-called you guys
conceptualize
it so that they you know the style
should be more contemporary
okay so uh jackson it was a it was a
competition
it's a design competition i if i
remember correctly there were
five five firms which took part so
we won the competition so i i imagine
they like our ideas
and our ideas when we presented during
the competition were already
contemporary
it was very much the same ideas that we
finally executed projects so i imagine
they were they were definitely for the
idea the only thing is that along the
way
because it needs to be consulted with
the grassroots and the users and so on
there were of course lots and lots of
questions because this is not something
that people are used to
i would say it was probably the first
contemporary most in singapore of course
subsequent to that there were many
others but you know the the
the people who ran the mosque project
they were very surprisingly very open
very open so what they didn't understand
uh we had to do research to show them
uh i think the the key here is to delve
deeply behind the expression and not
just
show them the expression uh i see some
of the new mods doing that
it's just a contemporary expression and
i think that won't cut it
because people need to understand what
what is behind it
and people emotionally connect with
what's behind it
yeah okay don't mind me asking i'm very
curious to know as well like uh
from your winning design in the
competition to the final execution of
the building
how much difference was there oh it was
very much quite the same actually
uh in this usually for us it's not a lot
of difference but i would say that in
this project
uh we did keep a lot of the ideas i mean
the the competition was based on the
premise of the arabesque which i
tried to explain it's actually quite a
complex subject uh it was based on that
uh and that that we kept very much uh
uh in the in the project as well but
there were other things for example
there was a change in
in the usage the number of classrooms
and all this obviously the competition
itself wouldn't the the scheme itself
wouldn't apply
but i think the ideas were there all
right more of the functional things like
right it's more functional thing i think
the main ideas were
yeah but you know i mean you need a
client who is very open-minded
who's willing to to to you know to
to contemplate other approaches now so
the answer is that uh
yes they are they're very open-minded
i see okay um
um
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
okay we're going to move to the next
question it's quite a long one but i'm
going to try to
summarize it it's
more for the singaporean designers to
maybe can uh
answer it says here that you know um you
know the
taiwan has started you know rubbish
separation since the
you know and um
and they have a lot of convenience store
but yet the wastage is very low
uh and you know we haven't really seen
this kind of uh
so-called recycling or low wastage
movement in singapore
so you want to ask like is there any
suggestions for how we can
so-called activate that in singapore
yeah no not easy question but maybe i
asked a partner um
frankly i'm not even sure am i the
correct person to answer this i'm not
the i mean i don't work for the
environment agency and what not so i
would not know
uh that much but i i do know one thing
for sure
is um we are
in year 2000 we did not do all this yet
so that's that's a fact
and rightfully from the question that's
a fact as well however
with the singapore green plan with uh
nea pushing out
um zero waste uh programs
we are trying our best here to to to
to at least we have started so what i
will say
is um like what i always talk about
um it's never too late if you start
doing i mean every step is still a step
forward
small then we are really still not fast
enough but i believe uh if we put our
minds together
we will get there and in the recent
years we see that there's really a
accelerated so-called commitment
for the green movement in singapore so
yes uh
i think the question is is valid that uh
we we need to get better and we
are trying our best here and sorry i'm
not really subject method expert in that
area i don't work for the agency yeah
yeah any any any news
on this well i'm even less of an expert
than khan
but but i i would say that uh you know
the the hdb
is probably the best place to start and
and because you know eighty percent of
singaporeans live in hdb
and most of the ways i can imagine would
be you know huge amount of waste
in terms of residential right so so and
and i know for a fact that hdb has
really started doing this
they started doing this in certain
estates uh on a trial basis on a trial
run basis
and you know the singapore government is
always very very careful about things
they take things one step at a time
and when they do it they want to make
sure it works so it's already started i
mean you can see some
some pilot projects actually doing this
and i'm very hopeful that it will
it will be you know multiplied by once
we get off the ground be very fast
you know there's a rubbish separation
and so on right
right um okay i have one last question
say how are you going here before ending
the session okay would you win over the
taiwanese uh
i wonder okay
[Music]
to
um thank you very much uh thanks to all
the speakers uh for sharing
uh wonderful sharing and also for the
audience for the really great questions
uh i think we're running short of time i
think i'd like to end the session and
hand it over back to
trina thank you thank you so much
once again pan ko kyung tati gangwa and
jackson
for sharing your experience with our
audience to our guests
thank you for joining us today and we'll
appreciate if you could complete
a simple survey for this webinar which
will also help us to improve on our
future programs
a link to this form is also being shared
right now in the zoom chat
and if you'd like to find out more about
the various upcoming programs at the
national design center
do scan the qr code that you see on the
right we most definitely hope to see you
at our future events
thank you and goodbye
[Music]
do
you